what's next rossi pie well next i love
this story the cincinnati zoo has got a
brand new penguin baby and people
reports this is even better they named
the little chick rose in honor of betty
white and her character rose nylon look
at him come on
look at him because you know betty white
did so much for animals loved them so i
made a donation you did your honor i did
that too for animal rescue on her
birthday
little rose will soon move into the big
habitat with 30 other blue penguins and
visitors get to see her this spring and
the tributes for betty white keep coming
i'm sorry look at rose so cute i know
i'm sorry it's like god that's what we
need to cuddle right now oh my god i
would do anything to cuddle a baby
penguin
i know
well uh everyone feels is paying tribute
to betty rightfully so over in michigan
the department of transportation just
christened their new snow plow and they
named it the betty white out which is so
cute it's the cutest i will take a betty
white tribute in any way that i can get
it yeah i just love that i love it so
much um
i just appreciate all the outpouring
constantly
for her and um okay so next up it is
time uh to review the things that you
write in and ask us to do in drew's
reviews
yes okay
so fun i never know what they're gonna
send in well today's pick comes to us
from sam callahan
and um behold dessert hummus okay
dessert hummus a hot the same old hummus
you know but mixed with sweet
ingredients like chocolate and today we
have brownie batter dessert hummus one
thing i asked
is does it have the garlic oh yeah
you're not a fan of that i don't i don't
want to be sucker punched with garlic a
little bit of garlic yeah but that there
is no garlic so it's like hummus is made
of chickpea olive oil this one has
brownie in it the color is a little
off-putting
all right i'm gonna try it let's see
um
i like it i like it too hey sam
i wasn't into it but now i'm into it
thank you sam
i am gonna dip a pretzel into it hold on
how's that salty sweet
right
you could put a pretzel in pretty much
anything and i'll like it mm-hmm all
right i like it time to rate it rossi i
give this about i give this a 4 star
if they change the color it could get to
5.
what about you
i'm going to give it um a five and i'll
tell you why
a lot of people want desserts but you
know are not looking to have the flour
and the sugar at times totally sometimes
go for it
this is a great alternative route i love
this avocado chickpea you put the cacao
in it
and you can have a really healthy
dessert and when i'm dieting is when i
crave sugar the most
so i need a little chocolate at the end
of the meal this is delicious i love it
thank you sam can you
can you do me a favor
can you just say cacao one more time for
me
[Music]